I'm Lucy I'm a higher laboratory
scientist Apprentice at the Sanger
Institute and that involves me doing
cell biology work for four days a week
and then one day a week I'm studying for
a degree in applied bioscience
our lab will take a sample of patient
issue from someone who has had a type of
cancer break apart all of the cells and
allow them to be at the point where they
can then reform into an organoid this is
a 3D cluster of cells that will
self-assemble in a micro scale and we
can then do things like drug screens on
that to see if a patient responds to
treatment
my job is to take Frozen vials of
organoid cells these are stored in
liquid nitrogen then to thaw them and to
culture them for about four to five
weeks to make sure that they are growing
that these organoids are assembling as
we would expect and to make sure that
they are viable cells that we can then
submit to a biobank
my day tends to vary quite a lot
depending on what my cells want from me
so some days might be really busy if I
need to split up my cells a lot to
encourage them to grow other days I
might simply be giving them more media
which is their kind of feeding solution
and other days I might be setting up
some Imaging experiments so it can be
very different every day I work within a
team of cell biologists and so I will be
liaising with them on a daily basis to
manage work and to kind of discuss our
lines and if there's anything that looks
a bit unusual we can then have a
troubleshooting session I didn't plan to
be a scientist when I was in school my
interests were more in the art subjects
I really enjoyed the Sciences but I
could never have seen myself as a
scientist I went to University initially
and studied history I really loved the
subject I was also a very curious person
and my University had an open access
policy for lectures so I started
sneaking into some of the biology
lectures and I became absolutely a
founded by what I was hearing it was
fascinating to hear people explaining
the natural world and how it all
functions and I'd often leave with so
many questions I'd be asking my friends
I'd go on Wikipedia and I realized that
that wasn't enough to save my curiosity
that I needed to explore this further so
I decided that I needed to finish my
history degree and then make that career
change in science
in my career I would hope to finish off
my applied biosciences degree become a
fully kind of qualified scientist and
then maybe look at doing future study so
Masters or a PhD to kind of gain
experience of managing my own project
when I was in school I used to think
that you had to be a genius to be a
scientist that the roots were very much
closed off to the majority of people and
the reality is that you don't need to be
a genius you just need to be someone
who's incredibly curious there are so
many different jobs and so many
different ways of entering the field no
one follows the same route everyone
follows a different journey into science
[Music]